follow the palestinian-israeli conflict
and you'll hear that settlements are a
major sticking point but what exactly
are they Israeli settlements are
residential areas built by Israel on
occupied Palestinian territory primarily
for Jewish communities but here's the
thing they are illegal under
international law in fact these benign
looking suburbs are actually a violation
of the Fourth Geneva Convention
according to the UN why because the
Fourth Geneva Convention which outlines
protections for civilians in a war zone
forbid States from transferring their
citizens to occupy land but Israel has
been doing exactly that since it
occupied the West Bank in the 1967 war
by building these illegal settlements
Israel is trying to ensure it retains
possession of that land even under any
future peace deal that's one of the main
reasons why negotiations keep breaking
down while Israel insists that any
agreement should allow it to keep most
of the settlements the Palestinians say
they can't negotiate over land that
Israel is continuously eating into since
the start of the auslan negotiations in
1993 the number of Israeli settlers on
occupied Palestinian land has actually
doubled to half a million and despite
the fact that in 2005 Israel did
withdraw settlers from Gaza and some
from the West Bank the total number of
settlers continues to grow so what
drives so many Israelis to live in these
illegal settlements well many settlers
go out of the religious conviction that
it's their right to live there but
religion aside there's really government
also encourages settlement by offering
lower tax rates subsidized housing and
easier loans and even though the
settlements are deep inside the occupied
West Bank their infrastructure directly
connects them to Israel the Israeli army
is heavily deployed to protect the
settlement over 200 kilometers of Road
have been built on Palestinian land for
the exclusive use of settlers and while
Israeli settlers in the West Bank
are bound by Israeli civil law
Palestinians there live under Israeli
military rule meaning they're subject to
checkpoints curfews detention without
charge and other restrictions that's
life under military occupation so what
does this all mean in terms of a
solution to the conflict or a
Palestinian state well the physical
presence of the settlements themselves
have broken up the occupied West Bank
into many small disconnected areas and
even though the built-up areas of the
settlements make up barely 3 percent of
the West Bank the Rhodes military bases
and security zones that form the
settlement infrastructure take up 40%
and it doesn't look like that number is
getting smaller any time soon so there
you have it negotiations stop and start
over how much land either side gets to
keep in the occupied West Bank and all
the while the Israeli government
continues to build more and more
settlements on that land every year